okay so I guess we should go ahead and
get started I meet I Segev a senior
kernel developer here at go from
research this is Gary sharm who will be
giving the second half of today's talk
and thank you for being here and I will
be talking about the all new Wolfram
script so Wolfram script is a new
command line program we had something
previously called Wolfram script this is
a completely rewritten program with
greatly extended functionality I'll
first be talking about the interactive
uses of Wolfram script then get a little
bit into the script part of book from
script and then Garrett will take over
and give us or more advanced examples so
what are some of the things you can do
with Wolfram script you can do one-shot
evaluations from the command line you
can do cloud evaluations including
accessing what's that a larger
you can do cloud evaluations you can run
package files from the command line some
extra bells and whistles or you can
automatically export results to any
format supported by export you can apply
operations to each line of the file as
opposed to to file as a whole and so let
me just go in here and start with some
examples so Wolfram script - code and
dollar version so I'm asking Wolfram
script to evaluate the expression dollar
version tells me I'm using 1101 for the
Mac if I want to evaluate this in the
cloud I just add - cloud to the command
line since this is my first time
accessing the cloud it's going to ask me
to authenticate and then it will go and
think deep thoughts and hopefully come
back with an answer and not too much
time
[Music]
well the answer there goes the answer is
1101 for Linux not for Mac because it
went to the cloud and the cloud is
running Linux for my second example I
will cheat a little bit because I don't
want to have to type a very complicated
URL but all of the commands are there in
the notebook if you want to peruse them
later so here I am accessing an API so I
just say API and that's not very nice
that usually works but I guess we have a
slow internet here so I just give the
URL to my API function and I say - args
x equals hello and let's give it one
more try and see if it behaves better
here let me as having reasonably good
results with the Wi-Fi earlier so let me
see if that behaves better
mm okay apparently we wonder if this is
the problem all right so let me well the
network is thinking let me go on to
something else so running commands
package files from the command line so I
say Wolfram scrip - file and give it the
name of a package file and why are we
not hearing anything should we be
hearing things
it I have oh that
I did plug in this is here one well
let's just do that
it went for August 2016 so there's a
Wolfram script pretending to be hell
and let's see heavy need an internet
connection we have made an internet
connection so let's see if this script
decides to work now it does not want to
work I mean I apologize for that it
would have said X's hello and why was
not given and then when I said I could
have given in addition to X I could have
given a y-value and it would have told
us X's hello and why is world but
apparently the network doesn't want to
talk to us right now so those are right
another thing I wanted to show you so I
have a file with some palindromes that
I'm going to show so you can see a bunch
of palindromes and something I can do
with dollars script input string and
we're going to take our input from
palindromes txt so what have I ate i p--
here so I said string reverse and I've
typed in this weird script input string
so this is a new variable in version 11
which represents standard input as a
string it's only available when you're
calling the kernel via Wolfram script
because it does the buffering needed for
this and so this is going to take all of
palindromes txt and string reverse it
and you can see it's completely
reversed the lines are in opposite order
and the numbers appear on in reverse
order on each line but suppose I didn't
want to reverse the lines suppose I just
wanted to reverse the numbers on each
line so now I can tell wolfram script do
this dash line wise now it's going to
feed each line one at a time to the
script and so you see the lines come out
in the original order but the numbers
are reversed on each line okay so you
see I've just been typing wolfram script
from the command line
which it's not necessarily your native
mode of operation on a Mac wolfram
script can and in fact does exist
outside of a Mathematica installation it
also exists inside the layout and it
sort of wants to be associated with that
layout if it's inside of it but the
executable is self-contained by default
it will search for the best kernel it
can on the local machine you can specify
a specific kernel using the - local or
yes the - local option - local path to
kernel executable and the exact setup is
slightly platform dependent so on Linux
typically no setup is required because
the Installer installs things into user
local bin and including wolfram script
if you customize that you probably
understand path and they'll have to set
things up yourself so I won't go through
the details of that now on Mac it is not
available on the command line unless you
run the Installer so when you download a
disk image from wolfram you get a little
folder that looks like this and it says
drag mathematica to the Applications
folder that gets you Mathematica to get
Wolfram script you need to double click
on this extras and run the Installer in
1100 we forgot to update the artwork so
it didn't say and Wolfram script but in
the 11:01 we fixed that and so so it's
no
very hidden feature of the Installer and
on the windows unfortunately there we it
was just one of the things we didn't
have time to do for 11/0 so it'll come
with eleven one it's still in the layout
so you can access it from the layout and
or add it to your path whatever is your
favorite way of working on the command
line on Windows so that's interactive
use scripts so one the scripts in
Wolfram script means that it can be used
to create self-contained Wolfram
language scripts and right now this is
supported on all UNIX like environments
which means Linux Mac and also cygwin
mingw and whatever other crazy windows a
eunuch simulation environment there is
and all options including cloud
evaluation can be used I will get back
to what that means on my next slide but
for now if you don't know what I mean by
a self-contained script I mean a file
which looks like this and has this
magical shebang lying on first but the
rest of it is just a normal wolf in
language code and if I were to run this
whoops and it will tell me no
expressions were given to square but if
I say 2 5 and X plus y then it will tell
me the square of 2 is 4 the square of 5
is 25 and the square of X plus y is X
plus y squared and so this first line is
special it tells the the OS kernel to
use Wolfram script 2 in understand the
rest of the file and then the rest of
the file is just a normal package file
with Wolfram language or Mathematica
code so script files must have the
executable bit as I already said other
than the first line normal normal
package files
and you know comments whatever else you
want additional options go on the
command line so an example of that is
this script here city distance kilometer
M so I you see I said - function that
signature city City so that says
interpret this as a function and use
interpreter to convert the two arguments
given on the command line into cities
and then it will compute the distance
between them so if I say city distance
and I say London and I say New York then
that will and hopefully this doesn't
require internet access
[Music]
it I mean you you can probably pass -
sandbox - to the colonel and you could
use interpreter instead of - expression
I guess I I decided I I trusted myself
to not do you know run of RM dash RF /
yes yes so it launches a kernel
interprets the file and and then exits
and you know theoretically you could do
- cloud as if you wanted your the your
script to depend on Internet
connectivity but yeah I guess we don't
have sort of automatic sandboxing that
might be something useful yes
hmm dad is an interesting question that
I don't know the answer to
I would guess probably yes but I don't
know that for a fact
[Music]
and typically for for I mean in many
common cases these scripts don't run
that long right and so I mean some of
them might but yeah right
typical you know sort of the use cases
for for shell scripts is you know you
want something to run at midnight and it
takes you know five minutes but yes mark
so there are the well the advantage is
you could make it set you ID probably
because it's right because it's a binary
it's not a shell script itself which on
linux the kernel launcher is in fact a
script and right you have all these
additional I mean if you want to use
things like dollar script command line
which Garrett will talk about and dollar
script input string those variables are
set by this rapper which you won't get
from just yes yep yes no issues with
that please please wait you can you can
ask me after you can ask me pretty much
any time Carlo and so I'm going to
skipped over the detailed instructions
because you know I want to have carrots
some time to speak and look it worked
ye oh ye of little faith so right but
these have sort of detailed instructions
of how to take these examples here and
turn them into actual script files on
your local machine and and play with
them and so with that I will hand things
over to Gary can you guys hear me all
right so I'm going to give you a couple
examples real quick of things you can do
using all from scripts so this first one
here is a script that generates a bell
sound given a base frequency
so I'm going to you so I'm gonna run my
script here with the base frequency of
400 and hopefully we can
can we hear that so we can do a similar
thing with a different input we'll just
generate a different bell tone so now if
I go back here we can look at how the
script works so starting off we have the
shebang line with our wolfram script as
a script interpreter after that we have
our script command line variable which
allows us to take arguments in from the
command line so we're grabbing the
second argument which is our base
frequency and then converting it to an
expression that we could use potentially
we could use interpreter or something to
make it a little bit safer but for now
two expression works then we're doing
our calculations at which point I'm
going to kind of gloss over that we
place it create a file for it export it
and get our Windows program to watch and
run it so that way it'll start at the
default program for it and player sounds
so this could be just an example script
of something you could do with Wolfram
scripts
it said generate something using an
argument and produce output that you
might use you go on to another example
here and let me just make one comment on
that so dollar script command line is
very much our V of the C world and so
the first argument is the name of the
script as you launched it so it would be
dot slash whatever or if you gave a
complete path it would be the complete
path and so on yep
so now I'll go through a quick example
of deploying an API to the cloud which
is if you're unfamiliar with it it's
like a function with interpreted
arguments so you can use that in a
couple different ways from Wolfram
script so the first one here I'm going
to avoid deploying this because I
believe it's under your account but this
script here or deployed API function
gets weather data generates a nice list
for us and then should print
so going to grab the UUID here let's
switch back over and we should be able
to use Wolfram skips with API and a UUID
along with a city so let's give it
champagne and hopefully and then that's
good enough that we can get back oh no
time to out so it should just be Wolfram
scripts I believe that's correct
I'm used to running it out of the
current directory out of habit so
Wolfram script should be how it runs and
normally this there we go so it
generates us a nice list of weather data
of the city that we've provided of the
city that we've listed so if I go back
to our script here we can see that the
city argument that I provided
corresponds with this city input here
that we've pretty made in our API
function for it to take in now there's
another way you can call the script and
that's the put - API oops mangling our
slide but that's okay so that's a
similar line inside of the scripts the
only difference is we're going to use
Wolfram script as a script interpreter
so I can go back oh now it is in the
current directory and I'm going to give
it a argument again and that should do
the same thing
[Music]
so many troubles with internet here but
ideally this would produce the same
output as before all right I'm gonna
continue on with our examples I think we
know about what we would expect from it
so this last example is kind of an
example of how you'd use images as input
and output with the scripts so sometimes
that could be difficult to do but here
you can type in and pipe out the images
so I'm going to switch over to our
scripts I'm going to show us our base
image so all I've done is open that
image up so we could see this is just a
castle and I'd like you guys to note
that it's got a slight blue tint so now
I'm going to use our script here and
input our castle
and output the resulting image so you
can see it gave us a little bit of
information there so we should be able
to start that and you can see this has
much less of a blue tint than the
original image hopefully we can see that
so we've got slight color balance from
our script so I can go back now and show
us how that works
so in our script here we've had a couple
different things
the first is that we're using script
input string is eat I showed earlier
from there we're going to import that
data as a PNG because we want to convert
that to something that we can use we can
do some quick error checking just to
make sure that it is in fact an image
and then we can do our color balance on
it so the way we're going to output this
to the script is we're going to use -
print to make sure that it prints our
last argument so it's a convenience
option for how you want the script to
work so that's going to make sure our
last argument gets printed and we're
going to use - format PNG to use the
abilities of export to export our PNG or
export our arguments in the format of a
PNG the last expression thank you so
once that's output you can redirect that
to a file and you can display and see
that as the images we did earlier I also
like to note that we have Erik so in
order to avoid writing to standard
output to corrupt our image we're able
to write to standard air and have exit
codes along side inside of our script so
all of the standard things you would
want to use from the script
yes everyone zero so if you call it from
another program it should return zero to
that program and now I'll hand it back
over to e-type thank you so I hope
you've enjoyed this little foray into
wolfram script so things were actively
working on right now is integration into
the Windows installer so you don't have
to hand handle that yourself
a standalone installer so just a wolfram
script installer so if you want to only
you use it on a machine with just cloud
evaluations then I will be available
also double clickable scripts so WLS
extension which stands for Wolfram
language script and like the scripts
we've seen will be a normal package file
other than the first line should be a
shebang line but the difference is when
you double click on that rather than an
opening in Mathematica it executes the
script and so that's a way to make your
scripts accessible to people who won't
necessarily want to use the command line
some additional resources our marketing
page new and 11 had some nice examples
Wolfram script has a dedicated page in
the documentation Center which is the
first of a new style of pages for the
programs which have been a little bit
under documented in the past so we'll be
refreshing those and a related tutorial
and so thank you very much and are there
any questions from people not named
Carlo
[Applause]
you